the wife of the limo driver involved in
the deadly crash in upstate New York is
speaking out for the first time on
camera 20 people including driver Scott
listen Nakia were killed Saturday New
York officials say listen akia did not
have a proper license to operate the
vehicle federal documents show the limo
he was driving also failed an inspection
in September DeMarco Morgan spoke with
listen Nicky his wife in an interview
you'll see only on CBS this morning
he is near the crash scene in scary New
York de março good morning good morning
Kim listen Nikki act toda said her
husband Scott had been working with
Christine's limousine for a little over
a year and she feels like he's been
improperly blamed for this accident and
even though authorities have yet to
determine what exactly caused the crash
she also says she believes it had
nothing to do with Scott it has been so
difficult because I think about him
every day and what was the last time
that you spoke with it it was Saturday
morning before the crash before he went
to work and when did you find out about
the accident I didn't hear from him for
about three hours and that was odd to me
and you sort of felt something yeah I
felt something so I called his boss not
the owner but the son of the limo
company I was like did you hear from
Scott and he said I'm glad you called me
because there was an accident what do
you think may have happened was Scott
suffering from any medical condition he
was in excellent health he was an
excellent driver for over 20 plus years
he drove a tractor trailer that's why I
know something was wrong state officials
say if your husband didn't have the
proper license to operate that vehicle I
don't know what that's about
because even if he didn't have the
proper license there's still what
happened and I feel like he still would
have got blamed hearing about the
violations with the fleet prestige
limousines fleet
are you bitter are you upset oh yeah I
am because they should have been more
responsible you you have a company where
you have people's lives in your hands
that's unacceptable
did he ever complain about all yes he
did what did he complain he you know
there were a few times where he told me
yeah but like I overheard him say I'm
not going to drive this like this you
need to give me another car so he knew
something was wrong with those vehicles
not really he trusted in what the limo
company said that the cars were alright
but please I have to say I feel for
these victims I feel for them I am in no
way trying to make it seem like it's
about me or my husband I just want my
husband to be vindicated I have to stand
for him because nobody else will
Kim was very adamant saying that she
would continue to pray for everyone
involved and impacted by this tragedy
Albany Times Union newspaper meanwhile
reports that Scott licinia was given a
ticket back in August for not having the
proper license to operate that limo and
that they notified Prestige limousine
the paper also reports that just two
days before the crash someone was trying
to sell what appeared to be that limo on
Craigslist the limo company's attorney
said the vehicle was deemed a rogue reti
after he'd failed an inspection in
September but the New York State
Department of Transportation told us in
a statement that is categorically false
the owner was warned not to operate the
vehicle and the vehicle was placed out
of service you get a lot of back and
forth but one thing is for certain for
this community it is mourning the loss
of 20 people killed in this tragedy
tomorrow thank you and
in a statement at Christie's limousine
said quote we respect the family and
their process of grief mr. Ellison Nakia
was a dear friend and dedicated driver
and we to mourn because he is gone at
this time we are putting our trust in
the investigations in order to answer
all of the questions of causation and
fault and you know you hear his wife say
that she's thinking of the families of
those passengers and of course we're
thinking of her - she lost she lost her
husband but there are still so many
unanswered questions when I was there
there were no skid marks the car made a
straight line across that intersection
it didn't swerve at all so just like a
Caroline to figure out right what
happened in those final moments she
seemed to question that even if he
didn't have the proper license she
seemed to be saying he was qualified
because he could drive a tractor trailer
but that still leaves a lot of questions
was he licensed to drive that truck that
that limo or not it's a very troubling
story but I definitely feel for her you
feel there there are no winners here you
feel for everybody this is everyone a
night reading yeah
[Music]